miss complan has busted but this should
help you get moving for now early on in
Star Wars Jedi fallen order you've
probably encountered a locked door or
chest that can only be opened with a
scope link so you might be wondering
where can I find one here's how for the
uninitiated a scope link is a droid
accessory that allows you to plug in two
terminals to reveal hidden passageways
as well as open up locked chests the
game leads you to one eventually upon a
subsequent visit to zepho but you can
get it sooner if you want to access
special rooms and chests earlier before
we go into detail it's important to know
that you can't get a new scope link
until a few hours into exploring the
game's second planet zepho so go ahead
and progress the story until you get the
force push ability from the underground
temple once you've got that Jedi trick
in your arsenal head to the weathered
monument area at the center of the map
any new locations that can be accessed
with your abilities are highlighted in
green in this area you'll find a cracked
stone door that you can now topple with
force push make short work of that door
and jump down to what appears to be an
imperial station situated around a
sizeable zepho statue proceed left down
the path going around the center piston
until you reach a wall you can climb up
scale upwards and you should find a
workbench containing a brand new scomp
link and voila you now have the means to
unlock all those locked doors and chests
you so begrudgingly had to leave for
later
and even better you're set to open up
all locked doors only accessible via the
scomp link in the game's subsequent
areas similar to when you get a new
force ability any areas that can only be
accessed with the scomp link will now be
highlighted on the map as green
unfortunately any chests you've left on
open won't show up so it's worth making
a run through any areas you've been
through again to see what you might have
missed
good work BD
and that's all you need to know for more
fallen order guides keep it tuned in to
GameSpot thanks for watching
[Music]